il m'a proposé dans le larzac visiter
quelques cimetière
et faire un stage d'accrobranche
réfléchir c'est sympa si vous deviez
partir tient alors jacques un top si
vous deviez partir avec une personne ici
ce serait qu'ils castaldi pas avec vous
ah oui bah bien soin pour qu'elle monte
à l'embarras du choix on peut visiter
plein de monde plein de plein de pays
plein de maisons plein de choses le
renard
guillaume genton parce que je suis
souvent d'accord avec ce qu'il est c'est
vrai j'aime bien ça avance bien ce qu
line ouais c'est ça natura est pas tout
à fait match nul 1 partout
il a tout prix de sa maman non mais
c'est vrai oui bernard montiel mois
isabelle pour rigoler et isabelle pour
rigoler à lenval à répondre aux normes
alors faire alors vous avez par ferrer
qui isabelle parce qu'on rigole beaucoup
avec les abeilles et delphi ou free mais
vous verrez je fais rire elle est drôle
et michèle fines
bah moi j'aimerais bien partir avec
nicolas j'ai envie de lui redonner le
sourire en fait
c'est la direccte a dit nicolas champ
qui est un truc non mais j'aime bien
j'aime bien redonner la pêche aux gens
j'ai rarement les gens viennent chez moi
je suis un peu leur coach au bout de
quatre jours ils repartent ils sont à
fond et toi il faut venir chez vous
kaddour et gestes pouvoir
moi je suis qu'à réprimer
et
vite
avec guillaume il me plaît cérébralement
et je lave ou aussi physiquement c'est
un jour je devais aller avec un homme se
serait lui
[Applaudissements]
je viens d'apprendre un truc on dirait
qu'il a quand même bien c'est en fait
sachez le il n'est pas être fatou
n'était pas tout
non mais voilà donc ça va alors dit ça
mais non mais c'est très bien mais allez
c'est fou les langues se délient et pas
que les langues d'ailleurs les noms mais
c'est vrai mais c'est dingue parce que
je suis content parce que vraiment voilà
cessé samedi benjamin aussi
mais c'est vrai bien à près de 100% pour
toi j'ai pu lâcher prise bien sûr vous
lâcher prise voilà c'est du rétro ouvert
non non non merci du coup on en voulait
les faire une clôture avec gilles gbagbo
comme il est dit qu'il allait bouffer du
cusm lui suggère de commencer par le
mien
[Applaudissements]
auprès de sa grand-mère
quoi c'est pas grave
[Rires]
quoi pendant la pub on peut y aller il
ya
je suis conne n'y qu'à voir une des
meilleures sangle abdominale ici ce qui
s'en fout tu crois qu'il fait du sport
et les coui
c'est plus bas le trou de balle un
[Applaudissements]
art est un film sans réponse québec en
vidéo on n'a pas de parole du
gouvernement qui arrive dans un instant
il ya là pour ça et qu'on t'envoie plus
ici
la barbe oui pernikoff sava nicolas très
bien c'est le quad est déprimée a
vraiment fait
un petit pas là vraiment c'est là c'est
vraiment là on prend un coup quand on
voit oui bah écoutez moi je viendrai et
delphine dans ce cas là quatre jours sur
votre bateau et grand plaisir on sait
pas gratuit rien que ce matin mais
j'adore la pêche combien
y'a rien n'est pas l'acteur est
tranquillement tout au bout de votre
yacht vous aurez à me croiser je suppose
qu'ils interne paddle en plus dessus c
est certes pas nouveau
tout vrai j'ai pas de bateau oui vous
poser une question oui parce que on
s'entend très bien franchement c'est
vrai oui professionnellement amicalement
mais pourquoi vous inviter tout le monde
sur votre bateau ait jamais fatou et moi
j'ai pas de bateau j'ai jamais invité de
personnes sur un bateau que je n'ai pas
pris chez vous je n'ai pas de chez moi
[Rires]
et dites moi vous avez prévu quoi où cet
été en fait cet été oui croyez vraiment
je sais même pas ce que je vais faire
demain on croit que c'est ce que je vais
faire cet été
je sais pas je vais voir je vais te le
paddle paddle voilà